hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades you may be expecting a map
change video from me this week but for
tonight chapter 2 is so big it's
impossible to cover everything so
instead our discord community and I have
found 14 map secrets you need to see for
yourself
these include Easter eggs hints to
future content and story and loads of
nostalgia from the original fortnight
map and I'll even add in some batch racy
things too let's do this
oh yeah and slap colder tomorrow in the
fort night shop please pretty please
let's go where do we start on an island
this big how about keeping up with Kevin
in this new world Kevin is now biofuel
for the island power supply and that the
power plant itself take time to look
around and you'll find this a desk with
Donuts strewn everywhere I'm sure you've
already guessed it already this is
indeed a nod to the Simpsons and homers
workplace at the nuclear power plant and
of course his well-known love of glazed
doughnuts this also leads into the
nuclear waste around the map which
creates freaks of nature kind of like
this monstrosity epic yeah this is a
thick skin but I wanted penny pretty
please while we are up here at the power
plant have you noticed the electrical
pylons have returned nothing new to see
here right well get this in your eye
holes the power lines are actually zip
lines I know what you're thinking holy
Sh Batman
me too jump on these and you can ride
all the way to retail Road each of these
pylons has floor loot upon it to grab
too easy rotations and relatively safe
too
[Music]
for our next location we are looking for
history the nostalgia for yesteryear
which gives us all that warm and fuzzy
feeling inside fair enough just just me
on the map get yourself down to sector
8f or HG it's a location known as camp
Cod but essentially this is the home of
our past kind of like junk Junction last
season here we can find something which
resembles is that you hot watch have you
returned no no this is too different you
are an imposter our search for hot watch
chapter 2 continues other items you
should recognize here are the fountain
from West world there's the sign from
lonely lodge in the trash here two and a
few cast offs from sunny steps but
here's the one which will make oh gee
players happy the original clock face
from the first version of tilting towers
is here in pride of place cracked and
broken but it's still here now made
that's beautiful
also around here you can see the Lions
from the football stadium or soccer
stadium and I think it was in Gotham
last season around the next corner are
those solar panels from frosty flights
and inside the main house is the bear
from many locations but we must know him
from the hunting star in lonely Lodge
awesome touch pot knight developers much
appreciated let's keep going with the
nod to the last 10 seasons over in
weeping woods in the northwest corner
there is the der burger and pizza pit
mascot heads during the live event we
saw them fly into the black hole and
this is where they've landed right next
to each other what do you think will
happen with this storyline will the food
fight continue the developers of
fortnight have given us Easter eggs in
the past around the TV show Lost have
you seen it it involves time travel and
polar bears and desert islands and
hidden bunkers it's confusing but it's
pretty good the bunkers we got back on
the old island were confirmed to be
inspired by lost this season another
lost reference has appeared the crashed
plane found up in a four the plane has
crashed and broken in the same way lost
begins and stranded all those survivors
come to think of it there are so many
similarities with lost and fortnight so
let's put a pin in it for now as it
looks like the new a geolocation
are taken from lost - hmm I wonder if
this is where the enforce has come from
and will they do battle with alter the
heroes of the piece then we would get
alter-ego dc-dc what I just moving on
[Music]
let's keep this on point those bunkers
from the last map as soon as we landed
we all try to find them in the first day
of chapter 2 leading us to this very
suspect island near the power plant I
mean it has telescopes hidden in bushes
so something must be here right and then
we found it under the innocent shack is
a secret bunker just like the old Island
I attempted to clear out the location
but then on closer inspection I figured
out it was a fake we all know there must
be a real one and we didn't have to wait
long because it was found thanks to
orange guy for showing me this in b6
under the water is the real bunker which
begs the question what will happen this
time around is it important or does it
remain a simple nod to the former Island
please let me know your thoughts oh and
just as I finished this I was told of
another bunker which is hidden elsewhere
on the island just south east of retail
row covered by a bush and two trees
destroy them to find it so hang on what
could these before could they be rifts
maybe later in the season or could they
be a fast travel network dammit that
would be good no speculation though we
just want facts at this point moving on
and now the ultimate nostalgia hit over
in the sea right of the island is a
strange marking get closer and we can
see that this is a treasure chest poking
out of the water but look what she's
holding it up
it's truckasaurus he survived Armageddon
and now lives under the sea as a beacon
of hope by the looks of him it's an
older version of himself as he has two
arms again and last season he lost one
if you remember
and now I think I have something for you
save the world players or people like me
hunting for a storyline here to keep all
this chaos under control there is a
redacted area on the map get your butt
over to retail row and follow the road
south what the hell is this it simply
has to be integral to the story but we
can look further into this save the
world peeps do you recognize what's
missing on the door the vendor Tec V the
V Box logo in save the world we press
this button to get inside that bunker
but it's missing in this day and age
could this be a link to what we've been
looking for for so long and the ultimate
question you want answering is thick
penny behind this door open up maybe we
should start bunker watch who's up for
that so we'll get 100 players and we'll
just simply stare at this doll in a live
stream maybe no there's a couple of
throwaway references to films on the
island you have to have a look at - has
anyone seen the film Ferris Bueller's
Day Off I know I know that film is older
than time itself
well well the home of Pharisees friend
is recreated in fortnight in Section a4
in the film they steal a red Ferrari and
when they return it it accidentally
drops out of the glass garage and down a
cliff edge tough break when was that
film made anywhere 1986 what another
film which gets a nod is the Disney
classic The Little Mermaid another 80s
film made in 1989 in one scene Arielle
saves a dude from drowning and that
rocky crag is in the game and even the
rock she poses on is here live your
dreams guys you can be the Little
Mermaid if you want to it's found at a 5
if you want to have a go here's the
question to mess you up though if your
boyfriend or girlfriend was a mermaid
would you want the upper half of them to
be a fish are the lower half of them to
be a fish so which bit would be human
the top bits or the bottom bits don't
think too long because it gets weird
[Music]
do you remember this guy we named him
Rock
the Dwayne Johnson after he was spotted
he went on to have a three-season story
line which is why I think we should keep
an eye on this guy a man made of hay
found over at frenzied farm he needs a
name what about Paul Heyman if you watch
WB week that's well funny if you don't
then I sound like I've lost the plot
please do me a favor and name him in the
comments we may be saying his name for
many seasons so make it a good one
please
[Music]
and to finish we're going to look at
some really weird findings some strange
goings-on here in fortnight's down in
the swamps you can find a cemetery a
newly dug graveyard really but venture
inside and it's a zombie testing
facility using slurp juice to create
more abominations lovely back over at
frenzied farm there is a racetrack
just made for lawn mowers boom that's it
flying lawn mowers confirmed if you get
yourself over to f8 you can meet this
iron man see what I did there he looks
like a stick man to me maybe he will get
up and fight Paul Heyman I prefer the
man made of hay so I punched this dude
in the groin because I'm mature like
that also did you know if you punch this
guy in the groin you automatically win
the game it's true if you don't believe
me check the comments below and there's
a few locations we should watch which
have potential erections coming up this
one at sweaty sands looks interesting to
me hmm
what could it be let's keep an eye on
them
so there we go there's 14 locations I
think you should visit in fortnight
chapter 2 as always please hit me up on
Twitter if you find something different
and we also have a discard for anyone
who wants to join in the link for both
are in the description below a quick
thank you to those who used my code to
buy the battle pass or anything in the
fort night shop you are responsible for
this channels growth so thank you so
much I wouldn't be here without you I
know that I appreciate you for it
if you want to see your name here next
week check the description below I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade this has
been a pleasure thanks for your time
I'll see you again soon
[Music]